I just look at that scenario as that  protective scenario situation again  let's just look at this your woman has  been disrespected you might not even you  might have been found that was a  violation but you looked at her and  she's not happy now you need to go and  do something and this is that thing what  I talk about as well when I keep talking  about men and women's protectors but  when we say it they want to act like  we're not but when will did that so many  women were like defending and saying  yeah they disrespected Jada her hair and  she got alopecia and this and they  forget all the other stuff that Jade has  done they were just like yeah that's  what I want my man to do